[Music]
when you think about wholeness
and
contending with these traumatic imprints
so you mentioned some say parenting
approaches that you disagree with
are there any
approaches or recommendations that you
think do more harm than good with
respect to
contending with trauma
or
moving towards wholeness
yeah any parenting practice or
educational practice that focuses on
behavior
rather than the child's underlying
emotional dynamics is going to be
harmful
because what we want
out of child rearing
is at the end of it there should be an
autonomous
human being respectful of themselves and
of others
who can be authentic and connected at
the same time that's our goal i don't
think anybody would disagree that that's
our goal for human beings now that's a
natural developmental process as long as
we provide the right conditions for it
but nothing in nature develops in the
wrong context so you know i could have
an acorn in my hand and the nature of
that acorn is to become an oak tree but
not if i leave it on my desk
right it needs you know water and soil
and sunlight and so on
a lot of parenting and educational
practices focus not on the long-term
goal in development but on fixing the
kids behaviors in the short term
so
we talk about kids are acting out what
do you do when a kid acts out
look at this phrase acting out what does
it mean to act something out
but when i say acting out when i say a
kid is acting out you will probably
think of a kid who's being oppositional
or or rude or disobedient or aggressive
but that's not what the phrase means
acting up means to portraying behavior
that which we haven't got the words to
say in language
so in a game of charades where you're
not allowed to speak
what do you have to do
you have to act it out act it out
if you landed in a country where nobody
spoke your language and you have to
portray hunger
you'd have to
act it out
kids are acting out their emotional
needs
the question is are we going to respond
to the child we're going to try try and
suppress the behavior
so much of what's taught as parenting
advice is designed to manipulate or
shape or suppress kids behaviors rather
than understanding the child
and by the way this is also true of
adults as well as we look at human
beings and we don't see
what's really driving them we just
either approve or disapprove of
how they're behaving but we don't make
much of an effort the legal system
specializes in not understanding why
people behave the way they behave
just in suppressing it
which is why
in canada where indigenous people make
up five percent of the population they
make up thirty percent of the jail
population
and uh indigenous women make up fifty
percent of the female jail population in
this country it's an absolute scandal
same in the u.s
the more oppressed you are
the more marginalized you are the more
you've been traumatized by history
and you know which groups those are in
the united states the more you're going
to likely gonna have it in jail
because the legal system doesn't
understand
trauma
it doesn't understand human development
and it
confuses punishment with rehabilitation
so as a result
in terms of supporting healthy growth of
human beings at
any level we need understanding of
what's driving this behavior and it's
not a question of allowing bad behavior
or or permitting it or encouraging it
but it's a question of
what are we going to do about the
phenomena
of
aggression
or drug use
or
in the case of children
rudeness or disobedience or anything
else what are we going to do about it
are we going to try and just suppress
the behavior
then you end up where we are
with millions of people in jail
and lots of kids with learning
difficulties and and and behavior
problems and millions of kids being
medicated
or we're going to try and understand
what's happening what's driving it what
are the social cultural dynamics
that are
driving so much dysfunction
and it's not that hard to perceive we
have the science we have the research
we're just not applying it
you